[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition du journal de
la rédaction l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale au cours du prochain quart
d'heure voici les principaux titres de
ce mardi 4 octobre c'est un chantier
d'envergure qui débute à trappes celui
de la zone de l'aérostat la commune veut
changer de visage et c'est tout
l'intérêt de ce nouveau quartier situé
entre les squares sand pergaud et
verlaine sur le front de l'emploi toutes
les initiatives sont bonnes pour sortir
du chômage l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines vient d'organiser
aujourd'hui avec l'association
rencontres pour l'égalité d'accès à
l'emploi un forum pour mettre en
relation jeunes demandeurs et recruteurs
et puis en culture l'artiste nicolas
sanhes s'apprêtait à expédier aux états
unis sa dernière oeuvre de plus de trois
mètres de haut et quatre mètres
cinquante de long et qui avoisine la
tonne de métal
le conflit autour de l'arrivée de
migrants dans les yvelines se poursuit y
ait aujourd'hui c'est le président de
versailles grand parc par ailleurs est
député des yvelines françois de mazières
qui s'oppose au président de l'inria
rocancourt au coeur de la discussion un
courrier reçu par ce dernier qu'il lui
demanderait de retirer sa proposition de
mettre à disposition de l'état les
terrains inoccupés sur son site pour
françois de mazières il s'agirait d'un
vice de forme il pourrait saisir la
justice pour le pdg de l'inria il s'agit
surtout d'une mauvaise interprétation
une chose est certaine les élus
recherche tous les recours possibles
pour reporter l'arrivée des réfugiés on
parle d'urbanisme à présent avec la pose
de la première pierre de la zac de
l'aérostat un projet d'envergure dont
l'objectif est d'améliorer et de
diversifier également l'offre d'habitat
à trappes est également de réunifier les
différents secteurs de la ville en
créant de nouvelles voies et de
nouvelles liaisons les précisions dan
goor l'anguille
voici le quartier de l'aérostat en cours
de construction au nord de trappes une
nouvelle phase de travaux a débuté ce
matin 62 logements supplémentaires
verront le jour dans un an les futurs
bâtiments seront tous équipés de balcon
ou terrasse un critère important pour le
maire qui veut favoriser la qualité de
vie des habitants
on va beaucoup veiller aux place une
sorte d'organisation à des auteurs n'ont
pas trop importante pour que le ca reste
à taille humaine et à
la défense tu as terrible pour
beaucoup plus doux beaucoup plus calme
en tout le quartier de l'aérostat
proposera à 850 nouveaux logements les
superficies varieront du studio au 5
pièces avec quelques maisons
individuelles un aménagement visant à
encourager la mixité sociale trap a
besoin d'eux je pense faire évoluer son
image et elle le fait très bien parce
qu'on a ce quartier là mais il ya eu
toute une restructuration dans d'autres
quartiers également donc c'est une ville
en mouvement avec beaucoup de dynamisme
mais le premier objectif de ce quartier
est de permettre à des foyers aux
revenus modérés d'accéder à la propriété
le prix au mètre carré se situera autour
de 3000 euros et les normes
environnementales devraient garantir une
énergie moins chère c'est important
aussi d'avoir de payer moins en terme de
chauffage par exemple
parce que selon le type de population
rom accueil je pense que c'est bien
qu'ils puissent bénéficier de je dirais
de tarifs qui soit abordable pour pour
tous
du côté des riverains les avis sont
favorables si certains regrettent le
terrain dans son état nu qui offrait un
espace vert la majorité voient d'un bon
oeil la transformation cours de leur
ville
alors que le chômage est en forte
progression ce mois ci vient de se tenir
à saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'opération
coup de pouce pour un emploi
l'association rencontres pour l'égalité
d'accès à l'emploi et l'agglomération de
50 ans proposait à magny les hameaux de
mettre directement en relation les
jeunes demandeurs et les recruteurs
nicolas kirillovitch étaient sur place
ça a plus rien à voir avec mes repères
que j'avais avant contrôle du travail c
beaucoup plus compliqué jordan a 28 ans
au chômage depuis plusieurs mois et son
retour sur la région parisienne il
espère décrocher un emploi dans la
menuiserie et pour cela ils participent
à l'opération coup de pouce pour un
emploi bilan de l'après midi trois
entretiens directs avec des employeurs
et déjà une promesse d'embauché
en fait on sélectionne ce qu'on a envie
par rapport à ce que nous propose on
voit ce que nous proposons c'est tout de
suite ça va aller aussi ça va pas aller
et puis ça nous défendent entre
guillemets notre bigras quoi on va
proposer un travail dans un peu dans un
secteur maintenant c'est à moi d'y
réfléchir c'est à moi de rencontrer ces
personnes là pour voir le salaire qu'ils
ont posés on me propose signaux
intéressants pour moi
comme jordan ils étaient près de 80
jeunes diplômés ou non à participer à
cet après midi rencontre une vingtaine
d'entreprises étaient présentes dans des
secteurs variés manutention aide à la
personne ressource humaine ou encore
transport principal avantage pour les
entreprises révéler des talents parfois
cachés dans un cv bien sûr ça permet de
faire d'eux de franchir celle la
barrière du cv puisque le premier
contact nous permet de déceler une
motivation et une envie une orientation
professionnelle qui n'est pas toujours
facile à traduire dans un cv parfois les
candidats ne mentionne pas non plus
toute leur expérience dans un série
l'opération coup de pouce pour un emploi
permet en moyenne l'embauché d'une
quinzaine de candidats par après-midi
après cergy créteil encore vélizy la
course solidaire interentreprises
organisés par special olympique c'était
à montigny le bretonneux ce midi
l'association organise des événements
notamment autour du sport pour changer
le regard de la société sur le handicap
mental la course s'inscrit également
dans la semaine du handicap proposé par
la ville de montigny le bretonneux
mélanie poker
près de 160 coureurs ont répondu à
l'invitation de special olympics
c'est la huitième course solide l inter
entreprises de l'association le but est
de courir en volley et de sensibiliser
au handicap mental courir jours à ce que
c'est c'est à la portée de tous aucun
une bonne action à la clé c'est encore
mieux on a créé l'initiative en faveur
des populations justement
handicapé depuis quelques temps
d'arracher les os et donc on reste
associé peut-être cause de prix c'est
important pour nous est vraiment ça
prendrait plus en plus d'ampleur
l'handicap fiche était moins connu donc
l'objectif est double aujourd'hui nous
faire connaître son bassin d'emploi mais
aussi communiquer ensuite pour l'inter
sur le handicap psychique
en france 700 mille personnes vivant
avec un handicap mental
l'association spécial olympics organise
chaque année des courses où se côtoient
tous les publics en plus des entreprises
on a trois établissements qui sont
présents l'établissement des mesnuls la
roseraie et l'alph et qui viennent
courir aux côtés des salariés je pense
que c'est ça qui est important ce que
les salariés des entreprises soit aux
côtés des personnes en situation de
handicap mental puisque c'est aussi ça
l'objectif de notre association changer
le regard de la société avec cette
édition l'association a récolté plus de
15000 euros ces fonds serviront à
organiser des événements sportifs à
destination de personnes en situation de
handicap mental
bientôt une place ou une rue michel
rocard c'est en tout cas le souhait des
élus socialistes de conflans sainte
honorine ils viennent d'en faire la
demande au maire qui précise d'avoir
d'ailleurs lui-même envisagé de longue
date a décidé le 2 juillet dernier
l'ancien premier ministre à diriger la
ville de 1977 à 1994
culture le sculpteur nicolas sanhes
s'exporte aux états unis l'une de ses
oeuvres partira mercredi pour miami elle
a été achetée par un collectionneur
américain nous avons filmé justement à
cette oeuvre pendant que son créateur
lure faisait une dernière beauté avant
son départ camille lambert
plus de trois mètres de haut quatre
mètres cinquante de long et une tonne de
métal une sculpture monumentale qui va
prendre son envol ou plutôt son bateau
acheté par un collectionneur américain
elle partira par voie maritime le 5
octobre pour rejoindre new york une
fierté pour son créateur
c'est assez plaisant
parce qu'à la fois je l'amène
aujourd'hui je travaille sur une voie
que je ferme éthier qui m'appartient
plus et je saurai me l'a de la refaire
une beauté avec elle qu'elle a quitté
définitivement
la pluie c'est une sculpture qui fait le
sale d'acier avec une géométrie qui
m'est propre cette pièce réalisée il ya
six ans inscrits dans le travail de
nicolas sanhes sur la ligne et l'
équilibre une réflexion débuté il ya une
dizaine d'années elle est aujourd'hui
devenue l'écriture artistique du
sculpteur afin de supporter le voyage la
sculpture et retravaillé un peu de
brouillard ce qu'on appelle enfin que
l'on ne peut pas faire peintures
sont les petits trop tôt mais la
particule voiture qu'ils viennent se
coller au dernier moment cédant son côté
un petit peu abrasif donc le lev
est
ce qui va permettre au vernis d'avoir
une meilleure accroche on s'est brossé
nettoyer un vrai lifting pour cette
pièce un peu abîmée par ses différents
déplacements elle doit être parfaite
avant son départ un périple qui va durer
trois semaines jusqu'à new york elle
rejoindra ensuite la collection de
l'acheteur à miami
nos terminons cette édition par des
sports la 41e édition de la ryder cup la
coupe du monde du golf s'est déroulée le
week-end dernier à austin dans le
minnesota aux etats-unis c'est la
dernière édition avant celle qui sera
organisée à saint quentin en yvelines en
septembre 2018 au golf national
retour sur l'envers du décor de cette
compétition pour voir ce qui attend les
saint quentinois en 2010 8,7 avec
michael et demie d'or
c'est un événement mondial suivie par
plus de 700 millions de personnes la 41e
édition de la ryder cup cette nuit du 30
septembre au 2 octobre à chaska dans le
minnesota
les meilleurs golfeurs de la planète
étaient présents sur les greens au poète
apercevoir l'icône américaine tiger
woods son camp le nord irlandais rory
mcilroy
le spectacle était également dans les
tribunes trois cent mille personnes ont
créé une ambiance digne d'un match de
football pendant la compétition
je il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
déguisés déguisé en voit beaucoup
d'américains mais on voit aussi des
déguisements européens ce qui est sympa
à voir également
c'est une pure atmosphère nous ne
pouvons pas la comparer à une ambiance
classique l'ambiance est comparable à un
stade de football
[Musique]
c'est la plus grande compétition le pays
l'un prend très au sérieux et nous
sommes très fiers de cette victoire de
l'indépendant directrice la ryder cup
capte également l'attention des médias
mille cinq cents journalistes venus du
monde entier ont été accrédités pour
assister à la compétition
je suis ici pour sky sports je m'occupe
des médias sociaux facebook twitter
instagram et jeu court ce qu'il se passe
en dehors de la compétition pour les
fans de la ryder cup
je suis reporter pour une chaîne de golf
en chine c'est ma première expérience
sur une ryder cup et je suis très excité
d'être ici est tombé sur le plan
économique plus de 150 millions de
dollars sont engrangés sur le site
pendant les trois jours de compétition
selon les chiffres donnés par les
organisateurs les visiteurs ont consommé
en moyenne entre 5 et 10 litres de
boissons sur cette ryder cup le panier
moyen d'un américain serait lui 200 $
dans les boutiques du site un impact
économique conséquent qui devrait
également se ressentir à saint quentin
en yvelines d'après les études que nous
avons réalisées en impacts directs liés
à l'événement on aurait à peu près 150
millions de création de richesses et en
indirect qu'il faut rajouter à peu près
50% donc un total de 225 millions
d'euros de création de richesses sur un
événement qui est un événement assez
court puisque c'est trois jours de
compétition c'est très important la
ryder cup sera organisé en france du 28
au 30 septembre plus de 60000 personnes
devraient venir chaque jour au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
pour assister à cette compétition
mythique
merci de nous avoir suivi tous nos
reportages sont à retrouver sur le
www.tv5monde.com le journal revient
demain 18h en direct nouvelle édition en
attendant les programmes se poursuivre
sur notre antenne
[Musique]